i don't do this with every interview i
go on take you inside my home i don't
but i'm going to hi my name's val
my name is val kilmer i'm an actor i've
lived a magical life and i've captured
quite a bit of it
i met val over 10 years ago and he asked
me to help him
with this mountain of tapes that he had
been gathering his whole life i have
thousands of hours of tapes and film
reels that i've shot throughout my life
and career i've kept everything and it's
been sitting in boxes for years
i was over there one afternoon and the
first thing i saw was the stuff from
behind the scenes and top gun
up just really special access the idea
of not only being able to see the behind
the scenes but also get to know this
actor who we all love but is such an
enigma in a way that to me was
so special in what i was drawn to from
the beginning
i was recently diagnosed with throat
cancer
i'm still recovering
and it is difficult to talk and to be
understood
we wanted to keep that intimacy as much
as possible throughout the movie
and kind of stay in the world of his
head and and his story his voice told by
his son living his life and his
experiences through his eyes and his
camera we had this idea for jack to
narrate the film so he was watching the
film evolve and getting to discover
things about his father even while we
were making the film
very early on we were quite certain
about approaching the storytelling in a
subjective first-person way i was the
first guy i knew to own a video camera
here we are filming ourselves is that a
video
yeah oh that's really cool though not
many people would be able to sustain a
first-person story but he's one of the
few who not only can and has the
material too so it was an amazing
combination of this incredible life and
then him having captured it and being
ready to tell the story i've wanted to
tell a story about acting for a very
long time about the place where you end
and the character begins
about truth
and illusion
we recognized that we had a very special
opportunity just by the nature of the
wealth of the footage that he captured
over the years to tell his story from
from his perspective and there's an
intimacy to that that you don't see a
lot of a documentary because i don't
know how many people have captured their
lives as diligently as val has we really
wanted to play with what is art and what
is life and what is real and what is not
throughout the film
what are the words that heal a broken
heart
that's the ball and chain around my
memory tonight
does that thing record your voice too
the stuff that i started gravitating
towards was his personal life and his
family what a wonderful father he is and
the things that we all can relate to
i'm coming to arizona
[Music]
my mother passed on
some of the deeper things around his
father
a death of a family member those themes
started leaping out at me almost more
than the stuff centered around the
behind the scenes of these movies and i
think that's the part that i really
wanted to share and i think what makes
the movie really special we were talking
about things that are scary
and you said the only things that you
were afraid of were your dreams
in some ways it can be
i think more impressionistic and more
emotional to actually just experience
these things than just to hear people
talk about them i i have a fear
better than ever
[Music]
they're overwhelmed
[Music]
that
for nine months simultaneously on three
different machines we were turning these
tapes from analog into to digital it was
a real challenge actually trying to
technically turn these things into
formats which we could edit with val was
always at the cutting edge on the camera
side so he was the first one to have a
vhs camera so all these cutting edge
formats then eventually became obsolete
shut the video camera i will keep it on
until we're rehearsing
accessing some of these tapes was a
process in itself we've gathered as many
of these old machines as we could we
were ebaying obsolete decks half the
time they arrived broken or they only
they only worked for like a few hours at
one point we had to get medical grade
vhs machines because some of the top gun
tapes had really bad tracking issues and
only these medical grade could play them
back without them skipping it was like a
scavenger hunt to try and find all the
different equipment needed
but also so satisfying once you get it
all in there because it's so beautiful
the different textures of all these
formats
made such a beautiful tapestry for the
film and and even when blown up big like
i was stunned at how beautifully they
all held up
[Music]
i speak cow
i've lived in the illusion almost as
much as i've lived outside of it it's
one of the things that they buy for all
that money they actually buy your
life
i think meeting any celebrity you expect
there to be a certain level of
guardedness
out of
self-preservation
but val doesn't have any of that like he
meets you and he's with you right away
there's no facade there's no guardiness
and he's incredibly open incredibly
generous and for me i was just kind of
taken aback by how loving he is you know
and how generous he is with that love
i always wanted this film to be like a
film version of val because val is such
a hard person to explain you couldn't do
it entirely in a book or by studying his
movies or watching interviews almost
like a film like this could be the only
way that could really make sense of him
and capture all these different angles
of him that complete the man he is and
that's kind of what we sort of set out
to do belle's also a brilliant actor and
has been in front of the camera his
whole life so we're very lucky in that
but i think there's also an intimacy
between him and leo which you can feel
through the camera and that only comes
from like years of friendship and trust
that they had between each other
i see myself as a sensitive
intelligent human being
but with the soul of a clown
i think people are truly moved by how
open he is in the film i feel like
that's what people walk away with the
most i have behaved poorly
i have behaved bravely
i have behaved bizarrely to some
i deny none of this and have no regrets
because i've lost and found parts of
myself that i never knew existed i just
hope that audiences can understand what
a remarkable man val is and get a
glimpse into his mind and his life
he's such a creative spiritual hilarious
energy and he has an amazing story to
share
do what you love to do so well that
someone will pay your wages for it
don't let go of your illusions though
when they are gone you may still exist
but you have ceased to live
[Music]